And did you guys know that we can further divide the Autonomic Nervous System
into Sympathetic and Parasympathetic? So essentially, the Autonomic Nervous
System is our self governing system because what it regulates we have little
control over. For example, it controls things like heart rate or blood
pressure, even digestion. But I'm going to bring Susan in to ask her a few
questions. Because I think that the Sympathetic and Parasympathetic, there's a
difference between automatically reving us up or calming us down.
&gt;&gt; You're right, Lauren. Under the Autonomic Nervous System, we both our
Sympathetic and Parasympathetic. The Sympathetic is often termed our fight or
flight response. When we are encountered with stressful or dangerous
situations, this is the nervous system that's going to be activated. That is an
opposite for the Parasympathetic. Here we talk about the normally relaxed
state. So, if you are relaxing, digesting your food, this would be our
Parasympathetic. However, if there is a stressful response, the Sympathetic
Nervous System will automatically be activated. Here we'll see that we will no
longer have blood going to our gut to digest our food. Instead that blood is
going to go to our muscles, which will allow us to fight or to flee. It is
important to note however, that the Sympathetic Nervous System cannot be
activated indefinitely. There will be a time in which it has to rest, so we can
replenish the neurotransmitters that have been released during this fight or
flight response. We'll talk about neurotransmitters shortly.